we've been working with the state for
the last few months
on planning uh for our clothing
vaccination
distribution and uh and implementation
yes so i was well aware of all the
i was really appreciative actually of of
the um
press conference because it just uh
validates and verifies what we're
uh messaging as well how is that going
planning
some of uh you know how you guys are
gonna distribute the vaccines once
available
correct yes the flu campaign was our
practice
uh platform for doing covered vaccine
it's worked really well
we've done some time studies we know how
many
people we can accommodate in a certain
time
frame with certain staff and that's been
very very helpful
we've tested drive through
different areas it's really worked well
for essential workers getting the
vaccine
first does that also apply to their
immediate family members as well would
they also be getting the vaccine
uh no not yet it would be only
the uh health care workers the the top
tier is the hospital
workers who are front line which means
that
they are working with coated patients
or suspect clothing patients directly
or like a laboratory working with
specimens
or vaccinating we're going to have to
vaccinate our vaccinators first so those
are
those are the individuals and it doesn't
include family quite yet
would you mind going a little bit more
in depth on who would be in that most
vulnerable category for example um you
know if you have somebody who is 65
plus but they may not have any
underlying health conditions
would that still apply to them or how
does that work
uh when we get to that tier yes uh those
who are over 65
and or have medical conditions so we
wouldn't differentiate between
the two we would just invite them all at
one
a particular clinic or or pod we call
them or mass vaccination clinics
yes okay and you know the vaccine is not
mandatory if you don't want to take it
can your workplace mandate that
well you know what i'm just the vaccine
manager
and a program manager so i really
wouldn't
uh you know really couldn't say to that
however i mean some healthcare workers
are
have do have mandatory vaccinations such
as
tetanus shots measles shots all of those
types of things
so certainly employers can require that
for certain workers based on risk so
it's really unknown at this point
what employers will plan to do sure and
do you think the kovid 19 vaccine is
going to become one of those
uh you know staple vaccinations i guess
if you will like tetanus or things like
that
uh it would depend on the pandemic i
certainly think in the next few years
it would be but um unless we
get everyone vaccinated and we're uh
until we know that then it's hard to say
whether it's going to be a routine
vaccination or not
what is the southern nevada health
district going to do to get the general
public
on board and what is your response to
those people who
don't want it right so what i usually
tell
uh individuals is that the vaccine
has been going through the same process
shorter certainly but still going
through the same process as
other vaccines and uh
they'll deem it you know what safe and
it certainly seems effective
uh when people say well i don't want to
do vaccines i don't
i um you know i'm they're afraid for
different reasons uh sometimes we work
with families
and try to educate them and and
the risk versus the benefits but
certainly
as the vaccine is rolling out and coming
forward
were we will be messaging
the those uh factors of the vaccine
but certainly we're going to just start
immunizing those who want it
and then and then there will be some uh
uh campaign with vaccine hesitancy
oh you know yeah so who who
world health organization has addressed
this vaccine hesitancy
issue and uh there are different way
why people don't want the vaccine so um
it's it comes from a higher level
i see and from from your standpoint do
you see that hesitancy here
in in southern nevada at all well
vaccine hesitancy i would say that it's
probably
less here in southern nevada than maybe
in other areas
and uh certainly there's a lot of
parents or individuals may not want a
certain vaccine
it's not that they're against all
vaccines it's just
certain ones so um so we
address that as we as we can
uh talking with parents but certainly
um there'll be plenty of work for us to
do just getting the vaccine into
the arms of those who want it people
aren't getting the vaccine
how does that impact our fight against
this pandemic
does it happen well yeah certainly i
mean the more people that have the
vaccine
the the um less risk that there will be
covered in the uh population
so at this point it's unknown what that
would be
until we get some more data and they're
they're
constantly collecting data and looking
at it and analyzing
but it takes a lot of time and resources
to do that so
at this point we don't know but
certainly looking at
other vaccines that we experience with
other vaccines
you know um there certainly it
would need to be at a higher level than
you know at least half you know some
people are frustrated a bit that the
general public
is kind of that last tier and may not
get it until spring
i think a lot of people are feeling
frustrations with just being locked in
all the time so
could you maybe talk a little bit more
about the process or the importance of
why we're doing this tiered approach
correct so it's been analyzed you know
they've been looking at this for quite
some time
and we've heard things from the last six
months on how this would work
and uh with any vaccine we look
when a vaccine new vaccine comes out
they always look at the epidemiology and
they look at the data
who is at the most risk for example hpv
we started with 11 to 12 year old girls
okay
and then what boys were added so it's
with any vaccine
that that occurs so they look at those
with the highest risk
and who and death and who is
who is that most at dying first okay
so those would be individuals that
are in the nursing homes and long-term
care
hospitals and then we also need to
protect our workforce so
who is at the most risk and
what workforce do we really really need
at this point
and that's why hospital employees were
targeted
and hospital and long-term care
employees
and our infrastructure so that's how
that all gets figured out and um
certainly i think you know it's going to
take us time
to immunize a million people
uh think about how long it took to
test a million people so you know it's
going to take some time and people will
need to be patient
um it depends on up the vaccine uptake
certainly if not everybody wants the
vaccine we'll be able to move through
those tears really quick
and we do plan to do that we are
oops oh they're out we
it went into sleep mode uh we are
planning you know to move through the
tears fairly quickly
and um and and you know eventually the
general public will be getting
that i would anticipate certainly
spring um i think to keep in mind that
the indications and the whole specifics
of who gets the vaccine
hasn't quite been solidified yet
by ace acip for example
it wasn't tested on kids wasn't tested
on pregnant women
so they will have to decide if there's
enough data whether that would be safe
or not
would you mind uh explaining acip
oh advisory committee on immunization
practices
so that is a that is a committee that is
uh formed with cdc and they have
been a long-standing committee for many
many years
i've been in vaccine for 30 years so
we've always gone according to acip
recommendations and what they do is they
look at all the research
all the data and they decide what
um indicate who gets that how it's given
um the intervals between and
they look at a lot of epidemiological
data so they give recommendations
they're not rules the recommendations
and then we
as health departments take those
recommendations
and as well as physicians and all all
health personnel we look at those
recommendations and we incorporate that
into our
uh orders or how we practice so
it's really important to us for acip to
approve it
we don't give vaccine unless they have
uh solid recommendations for us i see
and they haven't
reported they haven't given that stamp
of approval yet
no they they had a meeting this week you
know that and they looked at
indications i listened to part of it and
it seems like they're aligning
you know fairly well with what nevada is
talking about doing
and what we're planning on doing so um
but um they still need to see the data
regarding the vaccine in particular how
it's given
you know how do you dilute it all those
little
uh uh minor detail or not minor but
specific details that we're going to
need to give the vaccine
as more and more people those top tiers
are getting vaccinated
do you foresee any changes to some of
these mandates or restrictions
as we go through this process it's
unknown at this point i think it depends
on how much
vaccine uptake there is if we you know i
i think we'll have i'm sure we're going
to need to wear a mask for a while
um you know i know people don't want to
hear that
my family is like really mom i go yes
yes just
just do it and uh it and
whether and and we need to get kids back
in school
and so you know that's uh teachers are
on
you know tier two so until all that
happens
and it's just gonna it's gonna be a
while for us to get that vaccine out
we will we will be working uh
very hard to get that done and i have an
excellent immunization team
and i can't say enough about them in the
state has been very very
supportive so we're all working together
and to roll the vaccine out when it
comes to nursing homes
and some of the elderly that would be
vaccinated
would they would their family need to
sign off on that vaccine or how is
how is that going to work well that
depends you know
um some uh uh residents of nursing homes
i worked in a nursing home for a short
time
uh some some individuals have
a um uh oh a
power of attorney and would that person
need and they have to sign off on all
these
consents and things all of the care for
the person
and then some people have their own you
know so
it just depends and it does kind of set
up a barrier
but um but the the nursing staff at
those places they know how to do that
and they certainly will be um i mean
families will need to decide what to do
and and they should start thinking about
that
and uh there is information on cdc
about it um for healthcare professionals
i just saw
a notice today from children's hospital
of philadelphia which has which is
really a good backs they have a really
good vaccine center
the information and doctor often has
some uh
videos on vaccine so uh
that's very helpful so they really
should start thinking about that right
now and
and look at the websites and and uh
determine whether that's something that
they want for their
um family member great
and anything else that you want to add
anything i didn't ask about that you
think is important to get across as
we're
working through this vaccine process
right i mean and i think individuals
really really
start need to start thinking about what
they want to do and
whether they want to get vaccinated or
not and there are
many reasons why they would or would not
but certainly the healthcare workers and
those who are front line testing people
in the lab you know i really would
encourage them to get the vaccine
i personally i i'm really excited about
it
i have to say i'm i'm i am
i have decided to do so so um i
would encourage people to start thinking
about it because it's coming up quick